You're supposed to read this week was gray marble of the limbic system and Basal
Ganglia.
It's a hard paper,
but it's easy compared to the options paper,
which was Swanson.
And I had everybody read that last year,
but you know,
people were basically having convulsions.
And so I decided that it wasn't really fair to get,
you'd read it.
However,
I would very much recommend that you read it.
And because it's a bloody brilliant paper and the old,
you'll learn so much from it that it will be worth,
especially if you're interested in the scientific element of psychology at
Swanson.
He's a smart guy and that's a great paper.
And one of the things I really liked about it,
and this is what I'm going to an end about grades,
papers as well.
They're there,
they're there.
You're describing brain physiology and the relationship between that physiology
and behavior in a way that's sufficiently sophisticated so that I actually think
it's psychologically revealing.
It's,
it's so,
it's,
it's useful and important to know these things.
And I think what's happening,
you know,
I've been thinking more and more that that hierarchy that I'm showing you guys
over and over,
I really think that that's basically a map of the unconscious.
It's something like that and it's not that hierarchy I showed you isn't
obviously a fully worked out representation of the unconscious,
but it's,
it's not a bad schemata.
And I think what it's missing is that,
you know,
the at near the bottom where you have the actual actions,
those actions are actually sequenced into what you might call a motor melodies
that have a perceptual frame associated with them.
And then those are nested inside fundamental motivational systems.
And Swanson's paper does a lovely job of detailing the,
the physiological substrate for that,
you know?
So basically what he shows is that the nervous system is built up of
hierarchical modules that start in the body that basically start with spinal
reflexes.
You know,
sort of quick and dirty spinal reflexes that cause your,
your,
your people think of their brain is in their head.
It's like,
no,
there's a big part of your brain in your head,
but a huge part of it's distributed through your body.
So I re I re,
I remember reading and I hope this is correct,
that there are more neurons in your autonomic nervous system,
then there are in your central nervous system and the autonomic nervous system
is distributed throughout the body and it's the part of the nervous system that
governs all the things.
You're too stupid to take care of,
like how your liver works and how your heart should stay beating and how you
digest food and you know,
complicated things that consciousness isn't capable of dealing with and you
don't want to,
you know,
you don't want to downplay the complexity of those sorts of functions.
There are so important that evolution doesn't let you mess around with them.
So,
and then,
um,
you know,
the,
the voluntary motor system and the sensory system.
So the central nervous system,
well,
you know,
your spine is fairly hefty bit of neural tissue and then of course the neurons
themselves are distributed through your body.
So really your brain is distributed through your body.
And there's also a tremendous number of neurons in your gut as well.
And some of those seem to actually produce information that might actually even
acquire consciousness.
Now,
I don't necessarily need it the gut level,
but it certainly informs you.
So,
so Swanson's basic proposition is that it's a Piagetian proposition.
You know,
that you lay out these initial reflex of behaviors and then they're sequenced
into more complex melodies.
The,
the,
uh,
you know,
the lowest level,
highest resolution behaviors you practice and practice until you're an expert at
them.
Like,
you know how to grip,
you don't have to figure that out.
So you've got these elements of behavior that you can basically parse off to
automated systems.
And some of those automated systems are so automated that they're handled by
very low brain areas,
like spinal levels.
So for example,
if you take a paraplegic person and you,
and you,
uh,
if you take a paraplegic person and you suspend them under the arms,
over a treadmill and tilt them forward,
they'll walk has pretty remarkable because you wouldn't think that.
But walking isn't that complicated.
I shouldn't say that.
Walking could be,
can be handled by the spine.
Figuring out where you want to walk.
That's more complicated.
So higher order brain systems are involved in that,
but so you think about it as a hierarchy.
Now one of the things that that,
ah,
at Swanson really concentrates on is this is the function of the hypothalamus
and she'd tell you some things about the hypothalamus.
It's Sorta sits at the top of the,
of the spinal cord and it's,
it's not that big.
It's a little bitty brain area.
Although it's,
it's also not,
you know,
you got to remember that when you hear a word like hypothalamus or word like
emotion or word like brain,
those are low resolution words,
right?
The phenomena itself isn't homogenous.
And so if you look at the hypothalamus,
it's composed of modules and then those modules are composed of modules and
those modules modules are composed of modules and all the way down to the
cellular level.
And then there's some modules there and that goes all the way down to the
molecular level.
And then there's sub module is at the molecular level.
So it's really,
really complicated.
And to think about it as a homogenous system is just a low resolution
representations.
So the hypothalamus isn't an entity,
it's a group of functionally related entities that are composed of groups of
functionally related entities.